mein alter ich sehe gerade ein haus da
ist tempel ja kräfte als tempel so was
habe ich noch nie gesehen wie ich meine
lieben freundin herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge hero
zusammen mit epi mitkämpfer ich bin hier
direkt vor allem dings ist schneit und
orders in der schöne winterliche
verhältnisse du lieber auch von meiner
seite aus und zwar alter [ __ ] mit shader
ich sehe nichts sehen nur den schnee ich
sehe hier eine menge chocobos
ich denke ich werde noch ein dungeon
suchen wir noch zu einem unternehmen
wollten doch die rein oder nicht da rein
die engagierten kambodschaner das heißt
ganz viele level ja okay dass du ich mal
ganz klein bisschen lauter hier
ich hoffe ihr hört etwas flotter angebot
machte ja ja genau deswegen mag stimmen
will ich auch machen
auch hier ist ein pinguin dem dungeon
drin ohne witz was ich mache auch kurz
weiter bei mir
ich wundere mich schon die ganze sei
kein sound mehr
ja bei mir ich weiß gar nicht erst auf
75 stehen so hier geht's wieder am start
nur aus fackeln monika worten darum ist
aber nichts ich komme nicht mehr glück
und die kommen auch nur von unten das
ipad trieb er das tut was mich jetzt mal
boxen was ich boxen naiv wenn du nicht
rein läuft das ist doch sehr festen
verzaubert allerdings heraus so tot
unseren komischer zombie giftspinne
giftspinne giftspinne volker gelaufen
ja ok 1 donnerstag 1 bohnert weg zweites
paar hat aber ich hab ein schild das
schiff vor dem netz ab mach du dir zum
tod
da kam ich nicht wieso nicht damit wir
nicht locker doch recht blocken endlich
soweit der menschen nach so manchem ein
schild sony mit seinem schwert kannst du
61 wort dafür ist es die antwort ist
schwert und schild zusammen was
natürlich hatte ich muss da ja ich muss
gerade erst mal ganz kurz
ich bin sowieso voll ich habe relativ
viel armor spiel noch nichts verlieren
attacke ist noch ein bisschen sollte man
den turnieren mehr leute damit ich auch
natürlich ein bisschen was von den
bossen gärte land das sehr süß trotz
bester tod oder ist ein chaco müssen
aufpassen mit dem wort weil ich weiß
nicht ob da nicht alles kaputt macht
eigentlich nicht wollte später
ordentlich damage gemacht hat kann sein
ja die spinnen du ich habe nur noch
hälfte mitgemacht das ist welches
zweimal getroffen
ach so da warst du das was bleibt den
herzen schaden dreieinhalb mal so ein
paar unnötige attacke
du hast gerne luton hier sind jetzt auch
nicht so wertvolle sachen ich jetzt
nahezu nichts drin ein bisschen redstone
ich halte alle töten
das manöver die pinguin hier
wenn ich schon sehen dass die pinguine
drin sind der krieg schon direkt die
krise hier wieder abreisen werkzeuge und
so das viele reisen werkzeuge er ist
aber auch unnötig ab als das diamant
mittlerweile hängen da oben ach ich habe
nur kopiert ja gewöhnt ich habe ein show
coupe damit war es wirklich neu oft
einen ching chang chong wenigstens du
kannst das mitbenutzen hat der tag ist
nicht einfach hast du ich dachte es geht
doch einmalig nur einmalig wie einmalig
unbedingt dachte ich auch so man da darf
ich das haben uns sogar ein beirat mit
leichter waffen spezialisiert nennen
meint event show combo schon seit 20
folgen oder sowas ende erfolgt
schreckliches sind so ich will das jetzt
mal die magic mirror so genau
lange rechtsklick waren
ich bin ganz oben
wir wollen hier ein stückchen weiter
gehen es ist über es sehr schade dass
das problem kommt einfach hinterher
die servietten so spannend hier siehst
du mich wo es einfach so ein bisschen an
dir deine schrift das war nichts liegen
ja dass die einfach so ein bisschen
ich liebe eigentlich den shader aber
nichts zu sehen da wirklich blöd ich
habe mir zu beteiligen hier bin ich
schon lange laufen da blinkt nicht sie
müssen hier lang laufen
da sie keine dann so lange läuft okay
was siehst du dich in die richtung war
da ist für mich noch mal sie das heim
auf der minimap was sozusagen noch nicht
geändert ist und was schon wie kann ich
meine wahl windschutz reparieren
am amboss deine wolf schuhe meine
whirlwind whirlwind keine ahnung ich
glaube das ist verbessert hat ja ich
weiß ich hab hier hoch gefunden singh
kann ich so nicht sagen
also den war geil ich hab da hinten auf
dem berg wurde eigentlich hin wollten
durchgeschlagen
ich habe nur eine halbe sind jetzt
schaden bekommen du hast dein licht
geschlagen oha das sogar verzaubert ja
ja ich hab ja resistenz und stärker
laufen schon wir singen natürlich wann
hätte auch schaffen mit 19 schaden ja
ich habe auch mit 19 9 film
walter ich habe acht tagen wieder einmal
schlagen
nein nein das hat schon zweimal
geschlagen weiß dass hier für kaufen
sind hier jetzt gerade sternschnuppe
abgestürzt noch eine
gegen das richtige sternschnuppen nacht
heute da oben drauf ist ist ungewiss
haltbarkeit butter
oh du blödmann ziemlich allen einsammeln
also erstmal die ganze scheiße hier raus
fäden knorpeln was ist der länglichen
was ist ein black lichen und im vorfeld
keine ahnung vom baum dass wir raus raus
raus was ist aluminium gremmel ohr haben
ganz viele geschimpft wird die geilsten
sachen immer weg und behalte ich das
jetzt alter dabei liegt das jetzt so
genau was ich noch sagen wollte dass
seine nahrung erst samstag seien nicht
was heute müsste samstag sein und
deswegen vor allem die wunder ich bin
mir hero sehen wir hier ab heute abend
wieder geil oder livestream wie gewohnt
werbung genau du kannst du kannst gerne
mit dazu komme so ist ich bin samstag
feiern da ich hab keine feier party
party party mit robby bubble fanatiker
clara bibel alter geister alter wieder
auf dem korken der langen weg ist jetzt
wer sich dem al kaida die basis echter
beste alt bei den prozenten da drin geht
sprich gehabt hat wenig flüssig robby
bubble 50.000 50.000 krieger
stockbesoffen alter junge ist oder
wieder aluminium astra nicht für was gut
ist schon mal kurz was eigentlich
checkpoint bei unserer stadt
ich habe und die teleportation gemacht
das heißt wir können wirklich wenn es
wenn wir 20 minuten haben können wir
wirklich dann kommen wir fordern und
jetzt zurück wo gehst du hin eigentlich
bisher gelaufen ist ledig hier kann man
hier den fluss aber weiter aus
das war zudem wenn sie zum beispiel
nicht npd dorf wo ich gehe zum npc noch
dahin haben haben haben
bist du schnell aber ich frage mich
gerade
von einem pc überhaupt wenn du an land
her gelaufen wäre glaube ich schneller
gewesen
junge das ist ein richtig geiles npc
dorf da es so ein werk dass das mpc und
recht bekommen ist das geil alter ich
will hier ohne witz dieser berg ist echt
geil
wir müssen an herr der ringe so wissen
die zwerge mäßig wie geil alter gibt dir
das mal wieder die galle bücherregale
für mich eine kranken hilft mir halt
nicht beim abschied meister achso hier
kannst du dir schon ärgerlich wird
getroffen
manager bumerang ja kenne ich aus dem
singleplayer aber nur das teil ist
dieses teil bauch ab und teleportiert
die sachen zu mir ehrlich schon von
weitem so grasl alles möglich abbauen
und pflanzen und als nas bücherregal
einer seite kämpft beisammen haben hier
beinahe meister blinder meister
das ist ein mikro nomi camp age 2 also
zweifel was die kronia macht sich
sowieso nicht verstanden aber das fach
ich jeden zuschauer das jeden fall bin
ich irgendwie unterwegs bin und zwar
gibt's hier in jedem pc auf kisten und
so bestimmte tische die sehen wir jetzt
an ihn
ach so die fragen die kämpfe euch
übrigens stellt die können eben auch bei
ihren die kommentare schreiben
sterne was weiß ich was ich versucht
hier habe ich so ein haus hier muss ich
durch bauen
hier habe ich so ein haus da ist die
kiste drin da ist hier an bord drin was
kann ich das machen weil wenn ich eure
rezepte obsidian swat plate dann habe
ich hier einen handkuss stepstone
wildcard ja keine ahnung was ist da sind
so eine ganz komische teil ist sich die
leute die in die die richtig ahnung von
von headset haben am besten mal einfach
so ein paar sachen schreiben die sogar
sind und dann einfach so das rezept dazu
ja genau kaká eingesetzt bringt
eigentlich ein star peace das weiß ich
nicht das weiß ich auch nicht das ist
nur eine sache das war den ich sammle
die zwar aber ich weiß es nicht
ja ich sollte jetzt auch einfach mal ich
meine das sind fragen schnuppen stellen
zu machen alter ich bin ja übrigens
richie rich gerade
richie rich gar nicht den coolen
kinderfilm er sowieso ich was leute
meine hunde käfig hatte hunde die sind
beide gestorben weil die also ich hatte
drei ich hatte eine familie weil die
ertrunken sind er schon da war doch was
sie zum aufgenommen haben ja das ist so
traurig deswegen leute wollt ihr dass
ich mir eine neue runde banderole oder
sagte er so lass es lieber diese unten
die wallensteinstraße die zuschauer doch
gar nicht fragen meine passion am ende
sagen die augen beide länder holen oder
was man sagen alle hunde wandel aber ich
mittelfristig gespaltener meinung weil
die man schon was besonderes
bauser pietsch und das liebe damit
absolut kopf fahren einfach das feld ab
meinte sammelte nicht du hast alles auf
folien fast oder das volk viel gefunden
einfach nur im gingen generell oder
jetzt gerade generell ja ich hab ja
schon glaube ich vielleicht zehn
dungeons alleine ausgelotet weil ich
habe in all der kinder meistern deswegen
kommt auch bürgermeister zustande wohl
auch da langlaufen oder dass man die
richtung oder das von tannenwald da habe
ich schon genug wie sie damit kam ich
schon da sind wir hergekommen
ich weiß nicht ob man das doch darf
kacke dass ich jetzt wieder das ist so
wie beim mega projekt wenn du in eine
höhle finden wird muss als zehn
milliarden belaufen
ab hier ist alles nicht geändert wenn
man hier noch eine hütte alter das ist
der applaus geschieht aus gesteuert hier
ist noch einer dies noch sogar noch mehr
kaputt da wohnt so leute wie klassiker
ist hast du genug aufs andere der name
des kinder meisters kam deswegen
zustande weil ich nicht einfach in die
dungeons an der seite eingebaut habe auf
gut glück um die schatzkammer zu kommen
dann einfach gebildet hat und
weggelaufen hier oben das ist ein
bakterium das ist pink ist holz ich auch
nicht schneller
haben haben haben pink pink in der ecke
schlink hat der lehrer hin
geschichtsvergessen wegzuwischen
ich nehme aber einfach die sätze lägen
damit weist aber ich war nicht alles ab
den kindermord ihr drauf habt ihr nicht
shifting als hätte nicht shift drücken
dürfen
was bringt mir jetzt sagen wir bestimmt
einige hänger kippte das ding weg ein
vorfeld vorfeld viel mehr kann ich nicht
abbauen ich auch ein paar setzlinge da
war wieder scheiße wegwerfen lila lilien
habe ich jetzt
ich nehme jetzt auch ein bisschen leder
endlich mal mit weißt du wenn man dann
was braucht ihr sind gerade so viele
kühe im jahr 2020 locker kurzen
stückchen weiter nach unten hier ist
aber ich kann ich kann doch einfach toll
hier ist eine einzelne kirche have aber
ich kann doch einfach wenn meine schuhe
fast kaputt sind einfach ein amboss
reintun und dann reparierende vermutlich
schon ich weiß nicht mit welchem
material halt ne okay aber die sind
schon kaputt mein alter ich sehe gerade
ein haus da ist tempel kräfte als tempel
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen worden
war ich genau sehen
ich bringe gleich unter kindergarten im
hochbau kommt uwe baum und hier ist auch
noch sonntag will ich altere mit den
turm noch um dann eben kurz den tempel
angucken
aber ich würde noch eben hier die kühe
hier das gleiche muster beim baum oder
wo bist du dann gegangen wo bist du denn
gerade die comics zum leader baum kommt
zudem dingsbums zu dem baum mit den
komischen ärzten dran
keine ahnung welche nummer eins bin
jetzt beim leader baum
wir haben wir anfang waren abgebaut
kavai labor modernes das grausen ab da
hinten bist du guckst du bei mir der
richtung des kontur und jetzt dreh dich
mal gleich nach rechts zu sein
oder ist ein rektor ja reingehen und
gucken was da ist
so viel grün festung ja mit wem man fest
dass man hier in die historie eingehen
weil manchmal ein extremist glück aber
das bringt dir so ein tor
ja weil dabei sind auch gäste sind so so
eine art quest mäßig ist das puzzle
hingekommen faktor 10 gekommen
nein nein ich meine in der unterwelt
das sind die leute die lauf hinterher
kitten damit gibt die laufen daher die
leute von der festung laufen hinterher
gefasst machen
walter die sind ein bisschen blöd von
mir graut und scheiße ich hätte damit
sein laufen dürfen ich habe ihr gesagt
du sollst du nicht rein auf dem plan wo
ich jetzt gespannt bin ich bin bei der
friedensstadt gespannt ohne witz wenn
bei der friedensstadt christbaum ziel
direkt darüber nicht einfach netzer und
linksdrall einfach ohne witz natürlich
ein bisschen betrunken aber das ist
eigentlich übrigens chili
ich bin zwar bei der friedensstadt chris
pont aber ich meine ich habe ja die
teleportation schiff solle sich mit
einer in einem klick direkt nach hause
an mein bett ist das kleine stück solle
nee ich hab keine jährliche gm sollen
davor auch du wird man junge das heißt
ab jetzt keine und außerdem ich glaube
diesen komischen turnier wohl die killer
typen sind und so wenn ich bin jetzt
keine ahnung ich bin auch in einem
gebiet wo ich noch nicht gerade eine
reitenden fände eine kuh
was der eine reitet eine kuh will q
das ist der oberwarter okay dann fiel
ich jetzt nach hause ja und was soll ich
jetzt machen muss laufen dann sag' mir
wenigstens weiß man wie mache ich das
jetzt ja du hast auch die map
so hardy fuß wild gewordene alte ja ich
habe die map nicht wie mache ich ja ich
hab sie okay ich bin jetzt noch immer
deine koordinaten hass und die dritte -
4203 jahrhundert 1500 - 4200 1100 solar
okay so ich wollte erstmal das
bücherregal teil fertig alleine level
dadurch verloren schaffen
ich bin ja nicht gestorben deswegen
eigentlich ganz geil wir haben nicht
mehr so viel zeit wissen jetzt schon
wieder bei 16 minuten bei 17 minuten 13
minuten noch schuldig da will ich jetzt
noch schnell hier im grunde aber ich hab
keine knochen
schade auch durch das jetzt diesem
turnier nicht mehr warten konnten
ja was soll ich machen das ist immer
mein problem gewesen hier bisher der
gehwege sammler wird bestraft
ich bin der ober gierige hier ist jetzt
wichtig ist drin nicht mal knochen sind
jedoch nur hallo sagen ich reiste
ehrlich gesagt mein vorgarten nicht
einfach ab und zu eine verzauberung
schlucht kraus die meisten für alle
öffentlich zugänglich aber so sieht das
jetzt ja immer beschissener außen an ich
werde das hier nicht in bombay sonst
wird das aufgefressen
dafür ist mir zu groß
hier sind auch wieder nur veilchen drin
und sonst nix ey du blödmann dusche oder
verzauberung tisch ich mache dann schon
alleine gerade optimal
zack zack zack
oha hier sind voll viele spinnen kommt
ein bisschen angst vor sich nicht wie
vor sich ja ich bin raus gesprungen
so jetzt hab ich glaube ich die maximale
anzahl an hotels die man haben kann
alter steht gerade meine eigenen stücke
verschluckt alter das nicht gut ich lebe
noch erstmal das erstmal gut das ist
eine gute sache
olaf lies und das disco lackier und
falls ihr zuschauer wissen wozu braucht
man phoenix federn
ich habe nämlich eine königs die ist
weiblich habe ich noch einige funde aber
übelste schon genug
ich wollte nur noch so gold schule
machen damit man keinen fall schaden
bekommt dafür braucht man so was der
normale federn und gold ja gold habe ich
nicht so viel wie gesagt ich habe hier
über ein so reck gold nicht so schlimm
jetzt noch eben zu der kirche die die
eben am rand steht und der mond scheint
nicht an und das eine wunderschöne
perspektive henry die karten mal kurz
mal aus einmal so sieht wunderschön aus
so findig exit an sich wenn ich das mal
so anguckt und dann würde ich sagen kann
auch eine kurze sagen was es bedeutet da
unten rechts diese 38 steht im blauen
pfeile anzahl sowie feierten momentan
also was bedeutet die hose oben links
darüber wie haltbarkeit von einem ende
von einer rüstung ist auf einmal darum
umso mehr was so dass links vom
schwertkämpfe vz tisch nutzen erlaubt
aber nicht umstellen betritt kann jeder
zaubern so wie jetzt auch im crafting
table das schwert oder gut also nicht
gestorben bin jetzt ja alles verloren
was wir hatten alles ist an dieser
stelle beenden ich bin leider der bank
hatte
ich mach mal ganz kurz eben schild
ich hoffe jetzt kommt wirklich nicht
mehr dieses pack zeug was mir alles
auflöst das echt scheiße muss wieder
koordinaten sache nochmal -4 1200 und
1500 dann wirst du sehen
rund 1000 werden schmerzlich mit ihr
soll ich glaube ich muss mein haus hier
erweitern oder ich weiß nicht wie ich
das mache okay gut leute ich würde sagen
bei mir war es das schon mal
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen diese
folge mit cap nächste wahl kommt am
morgen wieder ursprünglich wieder so wie
immer halt 14 30 hier stehen die
koordinaten wo ich das nächste mal in
laufen muss ich bin hier in der kirche
drin und dann würde ich sagen sie uns
beim jetzt mal rein
vielleicht auch von meiner seite bleibt
geilo gibt momente gefallen hat macht
gut bist ein cha cha